promised economic competence but the
trust mortgage term or it goes on under
you hundreds of deals were pulled from
the markets last week you're the man
that's meant to sort this all out can
you tell our viewers when you think this
terrible situation might easily I know
how difficult it is and that's why when
I at the beginning of the year set out
five priorities for the country to halve
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and stop the boats the
first of those was to halve inflation
two of your five pledges are con
inflation half by the end of the year
the UK out of recession by the end of
the year if you fail on either of them
do you take personal responsibility
corsets on me personally I'm the Prime
Minister I'm the person who set out
those five pledges to halve inflation
grow the economy reduce debt cut waiting
list and to stop the boats and I intend
to deliver on those still break with the
British public if you don't deliver it
by the end of the year that's on you
it's absolutely my responsibility I've
told the public to hold me accountable
they should be able to have politicians
who deliver what they say and that's
what I intend to do